what else we got is Ice Cube a nice guy  in real life yeah sometimes they call me  nice cute it depends if you owe me money  if you owe me money I'm not that nice  all right is Ice Cube in a video game  yep I'm in Call of Duty I play the guy  who uh gets killed uh too soon in the  video game it's Ice Cube still what am I  still alive no  is Ice Cube a good dancer no I suck you  know I actually only do one dance which  is called The Gangsta two-step and it  only got two steps and I still need help  with that is Ice Cube related to iced  tea  uh no he's the homie we both got the  first uh same first names but my surname  is Cube his is T we don't have the same  daddy sorry y'all